[Music]
on today's show we're going to talk to a
brand new dad
who is tired of having a short temper
and wants to break the generational
curse
we're going to talk to a brand new wife
who grew up in a tee totaling home
who married someone who did not we're
also going to talk
to a young woman who is finally setting
boundaries
with her bipolar father stay tuned
hey what's up i'm john and this is the
dr john dolone
show a live show where we show up and
walk alongside people
going through all kinds of nonsense good
stuff
bad stuff all of it trying to help
people learn how to be human beings
again we talk about everything on this
show
from from family stuff to
relationship stuff religious stuff
it's politic all of it man anything in
everything that's going on in your heart
in your mind
here's the deal you're not alone you're
not by yourself
right i don't care i don't care if you
feel like you're alone i don't care if
someone told you
wow you're a weirdo man you're the only
one thinking through that or
if you're just looking in the bathroom
mirror with both hands on the counter
staring into your own eyes wondering is
this really all there is
am i really by myself no you're not and
on this show
i'd like to take a moment to highlight
what is going right
in the world i got an email from sherry
walker
and here's what sherry writes she writes
over eight years ago my daughter and i
met the man who would change
both of our lives forever not only was i
a single mom to an
eight-year-old girl but i was also
active duty air force
not many civilian men would be willing
to take a chance with this type of
uncertainty
but my husband buck walker
how dope of a name is the name buck
walker by the way
my name's john this cat's name is buck
walker chose to do just that
only after a week after we were married
we were notified that i was getting
transferred to texas from utah where
buck had lived his entire life
during that time he put his life on hold
to support me in a new job with
strenuous hours
and set up the home and take care of my
daughter abby
i was scheduled to work late that eat
one evening so he let me sleep while he
got abby ready for school
i woke up to him in front of the
bathroom mirror using a flat iron
for the first time in his life to fix
her hair buck walker with a flat iron
utah transplant in texas figuring it out
this is the same man who had limited
experience with kids and
no experience with sassy eight-year-old
girls now she's 16 and he even taught
her how to drive
i've never seen a father-daughter
relationship
quite as close as theirs buck walker
here's to you
hats off from nashville to utah texas
for to all the dads figuring it out
every day waking up saying how can i
make this one
work to the single moms out there duct
taping
and super gluing and still killing it
hats off to everybody but today this
one's for you buck walker thank you so
much sherry for writing in
on this show we're going to put some
positivity out in the world we're going
to tell the truth
we're going to walk alongside each other
and so if you've got a question for me
go to johndaloni.com show and fill out
the form
it goes directly to our inbox and kelly
and her team will go through them so
whatever's going on in your heart and
mind
give me a shout go to johndaloney.com
show
and fill out the form and kelly and her
team will go through those and see if we
can get you on the show
or you can give me a call at
1-844-693-3291
that's one eight four four six nine
three three two
nine one let's go straight to the phones
let's go to clint
in tuscaloosa alabama my man clint
how are we doing doing great dr daloni
how are you sir
i'm doing good all right so let's go
ahead and be honest with the audience
here
i know you clint is that true yes that
is true
all right so i knew you as a
undergraduate student
as a graduate student and you worked for
one of my departments at one point at
one of the universities that we both
uh worked for and then attended is that
right
that's correct yes sir so is it okay
stop saying sir and all that i know
you're from texas and you're in alabama
so
you got double double south there but
can we just get it out of the way that i
was pretty much the greatest boss you've
ever had and
probably am ever gonna have oh greatest
uh
no you were yeah i mean you're the
reason why i'm actually in the field of
higher education so watching you at
abilene christian and kind of grow in
your career path
um is just outstanding and so you've
kind of been a role model to me
and to many other i'm sure other
undergraduates
who attended the university um it's just
been a blessing
so thank you i thank you number one
number two if you've noticed i've since
left higher education so we can talk
after the show
and number three i will send you a check
directly to your inbox so i appreciate
you
uh i think the kids are using venmo
these today this these days and so
i'll figure that out how that works i
actually clint had to
i had to text my wife last night to have
her venmo somebody something yesterday
and i actually asked james
if he could burn me a cd and he looked
at me as though i had asked him
hey can you help me repair my covered
wagon and that's not
that's not a lie uh i want all the toby
yang wei cds and evidently they're not
see these are mp3s that's not why you
called clint
so what's up how are we doing man look
man i am doing
you know very well uh the reason why i
wanted to reach out to you as i've been
watching your youtube videos and
you give you know great advice for you
know people that i've uh you know i've
watched several videos i've been like
wow that's great i write it down
and i've been practicing it one that you
know i i
struggle the most with however is
having a short temper and this is
something that
is generational in my family so all the
coulter
man i just shouted out my last name
there um
but all of the men in my family they
basically
have this like short temper and i don't
know if it just passes along or passes
on
my cousins who are male they have it my
my brother he has it not as bad as i
think what i have
and it has just stemmed from since i was
a little kid i mean i can remember
punching a actually kicking a hole in a
wall because i was losing a video game
with my brother
so things like that and it was all
because
you know and i witnessed my father do it
i'm just having a short temper i
witnessed my grandfather having a short
temper
you know he was riding horse one time
and he was actually trying to break the
horse and
i was outside i was young i was like
papa come on inside you know food's
ready
and he didn't hear me so i kept yelling
his name
and then he yelled back i mean very
angrily and
kind of like said some word choice words
that i probably shouldn't repeat over
the year and so you know and i broke
down and was like oh my gosh you know
you know he hates me um and that
happened to my
with my dad too at times um and most
recent uh
yeah do you have little kids now clint i
have i have a little girl now
and uh she's about five months and i
don't want to
bring that into my family i don't want
her to have see her father like man my
dad
when he gets mad he gets mad like i
don't want that
i want to be someone where my little
girl who grows up
can look at her father and be like you
know when my dad would get upset or mad
he just kind of keeps it to himself he
doesn't yell he doesn't scream
he just kind of you know is able to
you know work through the anger and
that's what i'm trying to get at is how
can i
work through this anger um if you want
me to give you examples i can do that
well let's let's do this um
first i want to applaud you for looking
into the eyes
of a baby girl and saying no more
that this is i'm third generation short
temper
i'm third generation adult temper
tantrum
and this stops with me and there's a
whole bunch of men clint
across the country who have got to take
that sort of responsibility with who
they are
things that are going on in you know
automated responses that they have in
their hearts and minds
and that's the only way we're going to
fix the messes that we are in right now
and so dude high five to you i'd hug you
if you were sitting here
um i'm proud of you okay so give me an
example what's the latest one
um the latest one was with actually my
father
and it was about two weeks ago
i've lived out here in tuscaloosa for
about three years
and uh before that i lived out wichita
falls which was just a couple hours
uh north from where my family lives and
i lived there for about three years and
during that time
i only saw my dad once he only came out
and visited me
one time and and the majority of the
time he was like well you and your wife
y'all need to come down and visit us
y'all need to come see us and we did
often um because we were just a couple
hours but
anytime i would bring up why don't you
come up and see us there was always an
excuse behind it well we can't do that
well you know financially we're not able
to afford it
um well you know we're just not able to
because this isn't that
um and so i kind of just
let it go but now that i have a little
girl and she was born this summer
i've reached out to my dad a couple
times like hey would you be able to come
out
and it's a little difficult of course
with kovid and of course now he has some
health concerns um but
uh it's about a 10-hour drive from
dallas to
tuscaloosa and we've made the trip about
twice a year
and he won't come see you now
exactly and so so the conversation was
essentially i just told him and he has
another uh
he has a he has a grandson and they live
close to home and he sees him
quite often a lot and so
so in your heart in your head i can
guess where this is going in your head
your dad doesn't care about your
daughter that much your dad doesn't care
about because if he did he would do
these things
right he doesn't care about your new
marriage
he didn't care about your new job you
don't want to come see how successful
his young son's doing
all these all these almost
moral or character issues are piled up
into these actions that your dad is not
taking
all right or aren't taking which is he's
not coming to see you he's not coming to
see his name right
right right and so so you
you you grown man blow up on him
or grown man temper tantrum him
uh essentially uh yeah so i asked him
the question
or i just basically told him in a very
calm manner i was like look you know
this is how i'm feeling like i feel that
if the roles were reversed
and your uh grandson had lived 10 hours
away that you and
you and my stepmom would have driven out
and visited
and when i had said that of course i was
like this is just how i feel
china's son telling his dad hey look
this stuff
and that is when he blew up on me
like that short temper just kicked in
and he started yelling over the phone
which i do not respond very well so if
i'm being yelled at
i typically don't have a very good
response to it
and so i yell back
and we have this yelling back and forth
um and then we just hang up the phone
and then we text back and forth
and it ended up where a couple days
later was like i'm sorry and a text
message i'm sorry i'm sorry too
love you love you and that was it and so
now i'm at the point where i'm just like
you know i'm not even going to ever ask
him
to come and visit because i know where
it would lead
sure all right so here here we go clint
you ready
i'm ready here's a couple of things some
of them are
easy all of this is simple
and all of this is hard okay simple
doesn't mean it's not gonna be hard work
okay
so the first thing is this anger is a
gift as rage against the machine
eloquently said um anger
just points you towards things that you
care about
and so in that little exchange your dad
cares about his son he cares about his
son's approval
he cares about his son's um
his son's um like you know
approval of his job as a dad his
approval
of his his his role as a good man
right someone who'd go visit his young
child et cetera et cetera
um my guess is your dad doesn't have a
graduate degree is that fair
correct right so you've got this son and
you've got this
educated son now right so there's all
these barriers between you and old man
and anger points towards something he
cares about anger points towards
something you care about
you want your daughter to experience a
grandparent right her grandparents you
want your daughter to
experience her dad her granddad because
you love him
and he's probably a fun cool guy when
you got him hanging out and having a
good time
and anger points towards justice this is
the way this is supposed to be
right so all those things are good where
it's not good
is when anger takes over and you and
your grown dad
start throwing crayons at each other
right and then you take it offline
or literally take it online if you will
and
continue um you know thumb warning each
other
right on on the internets on the iphones
so here's what i want you to do to break
this curse and it is not
genetic it's not a wiring you're not
predestined to always have a short
temper
this is something you learned and was
modeled for you
you may have some gasoline and matches
in your basement
right which you may have a genetic
disposition towards x y and z
that's not a pass and i don't care about
that stuff
every time you lose your temper it's a
choice it's a decision
and so what i want you to do is
the next time you get angry the next
time you feel that thing frustrating you
i want you to think of if you've got one
it's even better i'm i'm taking this
from terrence reel
if you've got a picture of your dad i
want you to carry it with you in your
wallet or in your pocket
and every time you get mad i want you to
pull that picture out
and i want you to look at it and i want
you to
say out loud i am going to throw a
temper tantrum
in honor of you instead of
loving my daughter
because every time you throw a temper
tantrum it is a choice
to bring tension and pain into the life
of your daughter it's to bring gasoline
and fire
into the house of a little one in a
young marriage
of which your daughter will absorb that
tension and make it her fault and spend
her
lifetime trying to solve it which will
then
she will be modeled a great solution to
this is
short intermittent outbursts nuclear
bombs that just get dropped along
a a living room and
thus it passes to another generation
right and so every time you choose to
snap to yell to slam something to kick
something to bite back at somebody
i want you to say and that's for you dad
there you go i chose to high five you
instead of
honoring my wife instead of
being a controlled mature
grown man doesn't mean i'm not going to
get angry doesn't mean i'm not going to
get really frustrated
i chose dad to give you a shout out
instead of
modeling for my daughter what a healthy
well whole dad looks like
what a healthy well whole marriage looks
like
and here's the thing you're gonna have
to learn this you're gonna have to
practice it
but i've seen stories where
it can be healed literally overnight
with the idea that i'm not doing this
because it's gonna solve anything
because it
never solves anything i'm not doing this
because i can't control it because
that's
bullcrap it is
an homage it's a high five to the past
this one's for you oh man and what i'm
gonna challenge you
is to stop high-fiving your dad and
start hugging and loving your daughter
start hugging and loving your wife start
hugging and loving
those hundreds of students you've been
put in charge of start respecting
and honoring the folks that you work for
at whatever college and university
you're going to work for
go forward go that way and clint
it's such an honor and a blessing to
talk to you again we haven't talked in a
decade
because you're one of those guys that's
turning to face the forest fire the one
that's been
raging generationally and you're gonna
stand it down and it ends with you
and it ends with you saying either i'm
gonna continue to high five old man
or i'm gonna connect with my wife and my
daughter and it's that simple
you're gonna fail you're gonna have to
be graceful with yourself you're gonna
have to be compassionate with yourself
um here's the thing while we're here
let's just
i wanna talk about this real quick
because in clint this is for you it kind
of lines up perfectly
almost accidentally here as you
transition this
from being a third or fourth generation
anger head addicted to outburst grown up
temper tantrum thrower if you will
as you transition this you're gonna have
to be graceful with yourself you're
gonna have to forgive yourself
and self-forgiveness is an absolutely
essential
part of living and growing up and we are
terrible at it
y'all heard me say this over and over we
so often talk to ourselves in a way that
we would
never let somebody else talk to somebody
else
we forgive people around us if we're
mature grown up adults not if we're
children
wearing adult clothes but we forgive
people for hurting us
we forgive parents for hurting us we
forgive
politicians for screwing up we forgive
people for all sorts of things
but man we suck at forgiving ourselves
we're terrible at it in fact
this weekend or this week
recently uh peter tia he's got a podcast
called the drive
after you listen to mine listen to his
it's incredible he just interviewed
um kristen neifer uh kristen neefs
i think that's her name kristen neese
she is the
expert on self-compassion you have to
talk to yourself in a way
that is honoring and lovely
and respectful and forgiving self-con
forgiveness is a choice to extend love
and compassion and kindness to yourself
right it's when you have a really rough
day and you eat something you probably
shouldn't have eaten you know it's going
to make you feel bad like the other day
on the 12 hour thanksgiving drive
when i ate half a bag of sandwich
cookies i knew that wasn't great
and that next morning when i woke up
feeling like feeling hungover and all i
had had was junk food
i was compassionate with myself i had to
forgive myself hey that wasn't good for
me for my body for my parenting
but it happened wasn't my best self
let's go be better today
right unforgiveness prevents you from
living in the present and expecting good
things in the future
because you condemn yourself you
sentence yourself to some sort of
punishment that just goes on
indefinitely
stop stop unforgiveness is
costly the cost of unforgiveness is your
integrity your identity your capacity to
give and receive
love it's a lie to yourself
so this is for clint this is for
everyone listening to this
if you're trying to change behaviors as
we get into the new year and you are
trying to set
new goals and new year's resolutions
or you're doing hard things like
changing generational trauma like
clint's trying to do
you're gonna stumble you're gonna fall
if you're just trying to be a dad
just a regular old humdrum
run-of-the-mill dad
or a mom you're gonna stumble right
you're gonna stumble
so be graceful with yourself be kind to
yourself
forgive yourself and if you can't do it
by yourself get somebody that will walk
alongside you get a good friend
that will say i forgive you so you
should too right
thank you so much for that call clint
let's go to kirsten in cincinnati
kirsten what is up oh you know i'm just
feeling grateful for you and everyone at
ramsey solutions and that beautiful rant
you just did
and to be talking to you on the phone
well i'm grateful for you how can i help
this morning
good i'm pretty awesome so i agree i
fully agree
yes thank you so my main question
would be kind of where's the line
between drinking a lot and alcoholism
and then for me i guess it's pertaining
somewhat to my husband
and i'd like to preface with preface
with he's an amazing man he's very kind
and thoughtful hardworking
he treats me with lots of love and
kindness and respect and tenderness and
makes me feel loved
so i'm in a safe environment and it's
good
but i just noticed a lot of times well
we're both coming from very opposite
backgrounds on the topic
my upbringing well as pertaining to
alcohol
it was just never really around my
parents didn't drink my grandparents
didn't drink my great-grandparents
didn't drink we didn't have
alcohol really at family functions it
wasn't until i was older until you start
noticing like oh some of those family
drinks
they're those families right ooh those
families
and growing up in church it was kind of
a
alcohol wasn't great but it wasn't
really elaborately talked about
and it was just kind of don't get drunk
and
so that was the extent of that and then
my husband
comes from irish catholic backgrounds
and
um that's like all they did they know
how to make parties
that's right yes yes and all like
great-hearted people
fun stuff too but i will be 31 this week
and i didn't have my first adult drink
till i was probably
24 26 i've probably had four or five
just never worth the calories and i'm
somewhat of a controlled person so i'm
like i'd rather just do nothing
than risk trying to figure out them
stuff so
um but just him specifically
uh he grew up in a household though
where his mom was an alcoholic
and she was um that way pretty much from
drinking age until she was about
40 and then she passed away at 45
due to a health condition and then his
dad was very
black and white and he traveled a lot as
a profession so he'd be gone two three
four days a week
and he had a one brother who was
mentally disabled and um the capacity of
about a two-year-old
and so a lot of times he would come home
and his mom would be
passed out on the couch or whatever and
he'd have to fill in and be
the adult so he's had he's had he's had
lots of trauma there right
yes yes absolutely so great so i know
sorry go ahead i'll say go ahead so get
bring me down to the apex here
okay so um just we've been married for
two years
and i've known him for three okay he's
33 and 31
and um we i knew that he drank some
but before and it doesn't really bother
me when it's social settings or
uh just like here and there but i just
noticed
um it kind of creeping up more and more
and more and obviously
this past year trying to have the grace
of like well it is a pandemic
and extra stress and things like that
but just
where things to kind of watch for
because i so want to
protect our connection and not project
onto it and i want boundaries not
barriers
and just how to recognize
when it crosses down healthy and i'm
going to take a breath
sure okay all right so that was a lot
and
you actually called with one question
and you asked me about
five different questions okay yes sorry
um hey that's okay that's all right and
i can tell
it's deep in your heart and i can tell
you love this guy
and as happens to all of us who get
married
all of us who find ourselves in some
sort of deep relationship with somebody
and in fact i'll go bigger than marriage
this happens at work
this happens with friendships this
happens
in marriages happens in dating
relationships when you find yourself
in love with somebody when you find
yourself
trusting somebody when you find yourself
in relationship with somebody deep
relationship
and then suddenly a behavior that
doesn't line up with your values
doesn't mean it's right or wrong
inherently but it's not a part of your
values
is a part of theirs right and
you're faced with a different picture
of what something looked like i was
raised like you were
there wasn't any alcohol in my house
there was an alcohol in my grandad's
house
it was a shock to me to find out in my
probably 20's that my granddad used to
drink beer
and he said to the family i quit
drinking beer i quit buying beer when i
had to buy milk for my babies
it was an economic decision and years
down the road
i ingested that as a moral and character
thing
my dad was a homicide detective he
worked
every day in the lives of people who had
one drink too many and suddenly the rest
of their life
has changed right and
so i again i absorbed that as
a moral character issue
then i went to college and the statute
of limitations hasn't run out on all
those things and so i won't tell all
those stories but
i came to understand that there were
some really extraordinary young men and
women
who i got to meet who were from all over
the country who grew up with different
attitudes around alcohol
i had some close close friends two of
which are
brothers two of which are my best
friends on planet earth irish catholic
and you know what they had way more fun
than i did
they did they danced more than i did
they sang more than i did they
could play music better than i could and
they had a family that celebrated
big time right with good drinks and good
food
and good camaraderie and so those were
initially
value issues for me whoa this is as you
said so eloquently
one of those families and it turns out
that um second to my parents
their parents had a major influence on
me in a positive way
their um friendship has had a major
relation a major impact on me
relationally throughout my life right
and so it could go on and on and on all
that to say is this
your husband has experienced a lot of
trauma in his life
from mom passing away at a really young
age
mom being a functional alcoholic dad
being an on the road salesman
your husband having to be a surrogate
parent to a special needs brother
and and and and so what he has
is a model of marriage
a model of relationship that is going to
be different than yours
okay and so i've got way more concern
and concerns a dramatic word there i've
got way more
um i have my eyes closer to that to your
differing pictures of what marriage
looks like what relationships will look
like ongoing
than i do about alcohol
if you are safe and you are kind and he
is
kind and he loves you and he is there
for you
then i that's not my worry right now
um i definitely think it's worth
you guys seeing a marriage counselor for
for a regular amount of time like for
ongoing
to work through your differing pictures
of what a relationship's going to be and
you'll co-create he gets a voice you get
a voice
in something together you are not going
to be able to protect this by yourself
he's going to have to be invested in
this and he's going to have to do a lot
of
transition and change and you're going
to have to do a lot of compromise and
transition yourself
as you all you'll create a marriage
that's going to be different than
anything you all to have ever
experienced
now to go back to your original question
the difference between drinking
and being an alcohol addict those two
things are different
alcohol addict is somebody that is uses
alcohol as a way to escape
an addict is somebody that cannot do
without
okay they have to have this to get
through a day they have to get this
have this through to get through an
event they have to have this
to get through a week and ultimately
an addiction starts impairing your life
right it does usually start
not always but it starts in a rather
benign fashion
a glass of wine after work and then a
couple of days a week that glass of wine
turns into two or three
or i just have a beer a couple of beers
after work every day
and then on fridays i have four or five
and then saturday morning i have a
bloody mary just goes whoa
and then i go ahead and start drinking
saturday afternoon at four or five and
it's just i'm just having
i'm just having some whiskey just having
a bourbon that's it and um
i'm gonna class it up a little bit and
suddenly
i'm doing it every day suddenly those
one drink or two beers
a day become three they become four and
suddenly i'm not having fun without it
i'm not sleeping without it i'm not
filling the blank without it
and now you got a problem right and so
my guess is your husband doesn't have a
model for
someone who loves him and says hey i've
noticed
you going from year one to having a
couple of beers when we'd go on dates
or a couple of beers we hang out to
we're in a pandemic now and now you're
drinking every single day
so the concern one is the drinking right
that's fair
but he's not going to have a picture for
what somebody who loves him and is
wanting to have a conversation with him
looks like and that's going to feel very
judgy to him it's going to feel very
heavy to him does that make sense
yes and we had that conversation how'd
it go
over it because it was it was um
it's he kind of uh takes space
processes things and then comes out um
a lot of times like on the positive side
but it was never really like
oh yeah that was right it just starts
like drinking less like it starts
registering with him
and because it was that kind of thing it
was like oh once a week and now it's
like
twice a week and it went from two to
three and i just kind of said like have
you noticed
the past couple months that you've like
increasingly
done this and now we're here
and it and it was kind of a um half
response of
uh that's like just the way that i was
raised it almost feels like
alcohol to him is this friend and this
like
um like it doesn't feel like it's full
on gotten to
like that addiction part it's just this
coping mechanism friend
of like oh this is what i go to here
this is what i go to when i fish this is
what i go to when i clean my gun this is
what i go to
because it's friday night and those kind
of increased more and i did kind of say
like have you noticed that
and sometimes it's like i like the taste
or whatever sometimes he just then
doesn't drink for
a month like it just kind of varies from
the situation right and
yes so what you're gonna have to really
work hard at in this new relationship
you're gonna have to really work hard is
staying out of his head
because the way you just describe that
to me is
you asked him a question he gave you an
answer and then you judged the answer
because you didn't believe him
you got into his head and you were
deciding why he's drinking more
you got into his head and decide he may
just like to taste when he's cleaning
his gun
it may just be a moment of zen and
chilling out and he's having a beer
while he's cleaning his gun
or he's just having a beer with some
buddies while he's going fishing
that's not weird that's not unnatural or
unnormal and that doesn't mean he's got
a problem
right it goes back to
y'all are gonna have to work on not the
alcohol yet
you're gonna have to work on your
communication and you have a picture
where alcohol is bad i can hear it in
your voice you've got a picture where
alcohol consumption
is not good or right or to use religious
terms it's not holy
it is a crutch it's a less than
and he doesn't have that picture
and so what you guys need to work on
together is reframing it
and if you don't want alcohol in your
home you got to just be honest with him
and tell him
you're probably going to have to have
like say it when you're in therapy
right say it when you're the marriage
counselor and you've got a neutral third
party there
but if you're always gonna have this
tension around it if you're always gonna
have this
little bit of judgment against him
leaning up against him for this
particular behavior and i'm talking to
everybody now
this doesn't just mean alcohol this
could be going to the gym this could be
wearing a mustache dudes or the way
this particular um shoes look or
whatever the thing is if you've got that
little bit of judgment against somebody
i just don't like the way you smack and
you chew your food i'm never going to
say anything just don't like it
then what you're doing is you're putting
a tiny splinter
in your relationship you're putting a
tiny wedge between each each of you
and over time that wedge just gets
bigger and bigger and bigger and all
sorts of things
fall in there that never should have
been there in the first place
right things of not much consequence
fall into this gap and they
feel so big even though they're not even
though they're not
so the question the difference between
drinking an alcohol
being being an alcohol addict being an
addict means you can't function without
it
right it impairs your everyday life
having a few beers while you're fishing
with your buddies doesn't sound like an
alcohol addiction
it sounds like you have a picture of a
husband you have a picture of a home
that doesn't include it
and you and your husband need to get on
the same page about what your marriage
is going to look like
so thank you so so much for that call
kirsten i want you to to
go see a counselor a marriage therapist
with your husband
i want you to have an honest
conversation together and i want you to
call me back and let me know how that
conversation went i want your husband to
do some
work on his childhood trauma he's got he
had a tough road and it sounds like he
is overcoming a lot by continuing to
love you
i want to hear how that conversation
goes so holler back at me thank you so
much for the call let's take one more
call let's go to victoria in austin
texas victoria what's happening
hey john how are you so good how are you
i'm doing great thanks so much for
taking my call today uh you bet thanks
for calling how can i help
so i my dad
was bike or diagnosed with bipolar 2
a few years ago okay and i'm struggling
with how to have
a boundaries conversation with him
what type of boundaries well
um i guess we have kind of a
a non-traditional you know relationship
he was very verbally and emotionally
abusive with me growing up
um and you know i've as i've gotten
older i've kind of noticed it more and
more how
kind of on not normal it is um and so
you know just a lot of times i get
pressure from my grandparents to spend
time with him or see him
even though i can clearly feel that it's
uncomfortable
um i mean it gets to the point where my
anxiety is so heightened that i mean i
don't sleep
for a couple days if i interact with
them at all
um you know because he is bipolar you
know that honestly that diagnosis gave
our family a lot of answers as to why
he is the way that he is you know
growing up he was always
a pretty manic um he would
you know everybody walks on eggshells
around him he's
you never know what you're gonna get for
the most part you know it was
it was usually gonna be anger and that
was kind of just how it was
that's that was the normal you know
that's just kind of what i grew up
around
so you know as like i said i've gotten
older i've noticed that
you know i i'm very aware now of the
fact that
i've correlated seeing him with this
heightened anxiety
with you know not sleeping um really
just critically over analyzing
everything you know
when i go home to visit it's like okay
how do i tell them i'm here or
do i have to tell them i'm here it's
just this whole thing yeah
and i really just want to kind of take
control of the situation
and figure out how to say you know what
you know i'm an adult now
if i don't want to see you i don't want
to see you and you got to be okay with
that but i think
that kind of the little girl in me still
has a huge amount of fear
around him and kind of that how's he
going to react or
it you know he's probably going to get
mad so maybe i shouldn't have this
conversation that kind of thing
so kirsten i'm high-fiving you
i am double high-fiving you from
nashville to texas
oh sorry you're not kissing your
victoria let me read that one again
sorry
victoria you still there
yeah i'm here all right victoria i am
high-fiving you
from nashville to texas you are an
absolute rock star i
i every time a child
turns again we we had this earlier with
clint every time a child
turns and stares down childhood trauma
and says no more
that's when a high five that's not going
to be easy but i don't high five you so
here's the deal yeah
very quickly boundaries are for you not
for him
right your boundaries are about your
safety
your boundaries are about your
relationships
your joy your ability to function in and
out of every day
he doesn't get a vote he doesn't get an
influence
and he doesn't he doesn't get taken into
account when you are deciding the
boundaries for you and your family
period now bipolar to
bipolar one any diagnostic
is a context not an excuse
right okay he had bipolar too
so be it he doesn't get to verbally
abuse you
yeah he had bipolar too he doesn't get
to
fill your home with rage and pain
and not show you connection and not show
you love
and traumatize you and send you off
careening
through a lifetime of trying to find
connection through all sorts of
different ways
it's a context not an excuse
okay yeah well and and to throw a wrench
into everything
i think that he's kind of sensed that
you know i'm
i'm pushing further and further away and
you know for a while it was like
he you know he'll call me and just
seeing his name on my phone
like my stomach drops and yeah but but
listen victoria victoria
it doesn't matter what he senses
you're still letting him have power over
you
take that brick out backpack completely
what i was gonna say is that he he
senses me
kind of getting my distance and so he's
like hey guess what
uh grandma and grandpa and i are gonna
come up to visit you
and tell them this isn't a good weekend
you know why because you get to decide
you absolutely get to decide that and it
may be a really awkward trip one day
when they come and you don't see them
and that will be a choice that those
three adults
made not you
right okay you no longer have to carry
that burden
what you do have to do is draw really
firm boundaries and be very
clear about them the hard part about
drawing boundaries
where you're drawing them is they tend
to be kind of flexible
kind of loose kind of back and forth
and it sends mixed messages to people it
makes it very
challenging to know where your
boundaries are going to truly be
so you've got to take some time and say
i will not see him
other than these times
when my grandparents tell me they give
me the guilt trip and they give me
i will follow up with this statement
and i will practice letting it go i will
block
his number if i have to i'll pull out my
cell phone and delete it
because i get to do that because i'm a
grown up
and it might be for a few months it
might be for a season it might be
forever
but you get to draw that boundary not
him
and they call and say guess what we've
been missing you so we're all coming up
to visit
that's when they're testing how how hard
how strong is that fence going to hold
and that's when you say hey guys i'm not
going to be here or
i'm not going to be available this
weekend well we're coming anyway that's
great but i'm not going to be able to
see you
yeah because i in in no under no
circumstances do i want him in my home
especially alone
there you go right there you go and
that's your decision and it's going to
be
hard again i can say this over and over
and over it's going to be hard it really
is
but it's a choice you get to make and so
be clear
make sure everybody knows for somebody
with bipolar
something that's really helpful is a
letter because they can
hold it and they can go back to it
and they can go back to it in a in a
hypomanic state they can go back for
bipolar 2 folks they can go back to it
when they are
low they can go back to it when they are
flying through life and functioning
great
but that way it's not a one-time
conversation that gets filtered and gets
waved through it's something they can
hold and see
it might be something for your
grandparents if they can have a
conversation with you if they need it in
writing too
great so be it but it's going to be
about you saying here's my boundaries
this is the way it's going to be i'm in
control of my
adult life and here's where i'm headed
with or without you and i'm
so proud of you for making that decision
mental health diagnosis i'll say it
again i'll say it again i'll say it
again are context and not an excuse
and your boundaries are yours not theirs
good for you
good for you all right so as we wrap up
today's show
this is one of the greatest songs ever
written
and this one's for real i'll just get
right to it
from the 1998 shake your money maker
record
that's a classic legend record on your
way home today stream that album
shake your money maker 1998 by the black
crows
they sing in their classic she talks to
angels
she never mentions the word addiction in
certain company
yes she'll tell you she's an orphan
after you meet her family
she paints her eyes as black as night
now and she pulls those shades down
tight yeah she gives me a smile when the
pain comes
the pain is going to make everything all
right says she talks to angels they call
her out by her name
oh yeah she talks to angels
says they call her out by her name
[Music]
yeah she talks to angels says they call
her up by her name black crows
this has been the dr john dolone's show
[Music]
you